she's not even holding an equilibrium
there
let's just give her a few minutes
but she's definitely waking up i think
it's going to be worth releasing
that's good send her up river
well i'm glad we did that she deserved
it
well let's go check our other net maybe
we'll find a male that we can eat
tonight
there's definitely debris in this one as
well
here we go again oh here's one right
here
oh looks like we're catching fish there
he is
he said it's a male yep
something to eat oh there's one here
we got two nice ones there
that's payoff for conservation
i got something heavy here a live one oh
that's a big one
is that male 1 yeah yay
a little bit of driftwood and three nice
keeper
fish i'm glad that we don't have a net
full of fish because that
is more than we would need and we don't
want to overfish
that's perfect for what that species can
give to us
look who came hi
guys cooking some salmon for me good boy
dickle
tickle's been a great dog and i think
about
all the great times i had with him all
the adventures we shared together
and i'd celebrate that not the fact that
it might be the last couple of weeks or
the last month
that is delicious it's pretty hard to be
too much fresher than that
you know what i think makes it really
taste good is knowing that
there's one that was released out of it
today
i'm very proud of the fact that i was
able to release
a female king salmon to go up and
finish spawning this life has provided a
really really good life for me
and i just want other people to have the
opportunity to experience that
cheers
[Music]
you